Let's go next to our caller from the six five
zero area code.
Who's calling today from six five zero?
Hi, David, this is so great.
Hey, how's it.
What's going on?
And it hasn't gone on good.
So I'm an international student from from
Mexico.
Yeah, I was just wondering whether you managed
to see the new ruling from the Trump administration
that is just making it pretty hard for international
students.
Get back in the states.
Yeah.
Most universities bend over backwards.
So I did see it.
I did see it.
I'm I'm against the ruling.
If you know, how can it be that it's safe
enough to open all elementary and high schools
and yet it is too dangerous to allow a relatively
modest number of international students to
come in?
It strikes me as discriminatory.
Like, either it's safe to do schools or it's
not as my take.
But I heard and I've not read a lot into this,
you maybe know more about this than I do that
if schools say that they've assigned an individual
teacher to you for in-person learning, which
can just be like a five minute check in per
week, that technically then the students would
be allowed to come in.
Have you heard anything about that?
Yes.
So we basically have like we have to take
a certain number of credit hours as in person
or like hybrid.
Right.
In order for us to be able to take like the
rest of our course load online.
Yeah, it I mean, it just seems to have a lot
of loopholes in it.
And to me, it just seems like a strategy to
get the schools to reopen forcibly, because
I just I mean, I'm studying computer science
and like I can't imagine the computer science
department at my university operating without
international students right there.
The teacher is they are at like they weren't
student officers like I did.
Yeah.
It's just it's very draconian.
It seems counterproductive.
Well, it seems to me that either way, it will
give the Trump the Trump administration something
that they like.
Either they will keep keep a bunch of foreigners
out.
That's one possibility.
And they would welcome that or it would get
schools to reopen even when they don't really
think it's the right thing to do, which is
also what the Trump administration wants.
So it's almost like they're going to get something
they like out of this.
No, I agreed.
What did you think of the end game of of opening
schools?
It just seems like a bomb ready to explode
like you've done.
You have a bunch of cases, right?
A visual household.
You send all the kids to the same place to
infecting them.
They all go back home to their parents and
get them infected.
Yeah, I think we I think basically the hope
is the bomb won't go off until after November
3rd.
Like, I think the calculation is schools won't.
I believe that no schools open earlier than
late August here in Massachusetts.
It's usually September.
I think there's some states that open earlier.
I think the calculation is if we get schools
open, we get the publicity of schools being
open.
Parents are able to go back to their jobs,
maybe because they're not home watching their
kids.
So the economy will show some better jobs
numbers and hopefully it'll all stay relatively
under control until November 3rd and it'll
get Trump reelected.
I don't think it'll work.
I mean, if you look at we it's right now as
we're filming this, it's the early afternoon.
We already are at twenty five thousand new
cases today.
It's only halfway through the day.
Most states don't report until the afternoon.
It seems like it's not going to work.
But I think that's their idea.
I don't think it's going to work.
It's crazy.
All right, my friend.
I hope it works out.
And I appreciate you letting me know what's
going on.
Been you.
OK.
Take care.
Likewise.
The pleasure is all on this side of the microphone.